Sunnis and Shia both practice Islam but
what's the difference a disagreement
1400 years ago over one simple question
who would lead the Muslim community
following the death of the Prophet
Muhammad in 632 ad some believed that
the Prophet Muhammad's cousin Hayley was
the rightful immediate air while others
thought abou Beckett one of his oldest
friends was the better choice today they
share a lot of similar beliefs and
practices but she I believe religious
leadership must come from the Prophet
Muhammad's descendants while Sunnis
don't of the 1.6 billion Muslims in the
world about 87 to 90 percent are Sunni
and 10 to 13 percent are Shia
you